wenn von russischen traditionen die rede
ist was verliert also spontan eine
matroschka puppen wodka dass kalinka
lied und gift attentate russland aber
all die erkrankte nachdem er in seinem
hotelzimmer aus einer vergifteten
wasserflasche betrunken hatte sagen
helfer
alexej nawalny ist zur seit jahren
stärksten alternative zu russischen
dauerwurst putin herangewachsen
tja man mag es kaum glauben aber
wladimir putin regiert noch länger als
angela merkel und so einem dauer
herrscher zu stark auf die füße zu
treten kann schon durchaus ein risiko
darstellen oder sagen wir es mal so
absolut kein risiko wäre so was in einem
land mit robuster rechtsstaatlichkeit in
dem geleaste unter demokratischer
kontrolle stehen und keine
uneingeschränkte macht besitzen
politische oder wirtschaftliche gegner
der herrschenden moment natura
auszuschalten aber der reihe nach denn
das bald ihren geheimdiensten vieles
nicht mit rechten dingen zugehen sollte
allen ziemlich klar sein
darüber haben wir euch zum beispiel in
einem video über die ns erzählt und das
zeigen auch so unglaubliche fälle wie
der des julian assange aber immer wenn
menschen auf grausame und eigentlich
vollkommen offensichtlicher weise durch
geheimdienste vernichtet werden das
heißt wenn dies ganz unbestreitbar vor
den augen der öffentlichkeit geschieht
wird von den regierungen alles
abgewickelt der verdacht sonstwohin
geleckt und gerade aufgrund der ganzen
augenscheinlich kite und eindeutigkeit
behaupten sie dann auch das könnte doch
gar nicht gewesen sein
die werden doch nicht so blöd wie machen
der offensichtlich und plumpe zu
vernichten also was kann man glauben wie
soll man der wahrheit in diesen fällen
auf den grund gehen nun am ende dieses
videos dass du bescheid wissen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viele von euch erinnern sich vielleicht
noch an den fall des überläufers herr
gatekeeper auf ihn und seine tochter
wurden im jahr 2018 durch zwei russische
agenten ein giftanschlag auf britischem
boden also auf fremdem territorium zum
einsatz kam einnahmen des namens 234 aus
der nordgruppe ziemlich harter tobak
aber die politik russlands ganz und gar
nicht ungewöhnlich dass im gegenteil
eigentlich nicht wie bereits eingangs
erwähnt um eine tradition der russischen
politik und eine tradition von visual
politik ist wie er sicher schon wissen
der blick zurück in die geschichte
also wie weit reicht diese unrühmliche
russische tradition zurück nun im jahr
jetzt 100 ich muss nicht nur das spiel
wurde prinz dimitri schirm jaka
vergiftet er bekam man ebenso leckeres
gibt tödliches abendessen serviert
küchen mit arsene 1610 wurde ein anderes
geschäft wird michael skuppin schutzki
von seiner eigenen frau vergiftet weil
der zar ihn als bedrohung betrachtet ihr
goldenes zeitalter erlebte die
beseitigung politische opponenten jedoch
während der ära der sowjetunion
[Musik]
leni selbst der vater der russischen
bolschewiki bewegung fördert den aufbau
eines netzwerks von geheim labors zur
erforschung und entwicklung neuer gifte
und stalin ein echter fan des mordens
baute dieses noch weiter aus das
berühmteste war epics im volksmund als
kamera bekannt das ursprüngliche ziel
dieser laboratorien bestand darin
vorhandene gifte zu testen und zu
perfektionieren
ich sage jetzt hatten dabei keinerlei
skrupel lebende gefangene aus ihren
gulags als versuchskaninchen für ihre
brutalen gift es zu missbrauchen ganz im
stile des kassel schlecht dass doktor
mengele oder der japanischen einheit 731
töteten sie auf grausamste weise und sie
lege unschuldige menschen mit senfgas re
ziehen die die toxine couragiert und
vielen anderen giftstoffen
damit nahm auch ein schreckliches
wettrüsten sein ausgang das fatale
wettrüsten mit chemiewaffen
das giftige erbe der sowjetunion
was weißt du warum sind in russland
gerade gift so beliebt es gibt doch noch
nicht andere methoden und menschen
umzubringen
sie haben einige vorteile die sie selbst
schnell geräuschlos und man kann mit
ihnen einen natürlichen tod nachahmen in
der tat geplant ist den sowjets sehr
schnell mögliche substanzen zu
entwickeln die völlig unentdeckt bleiben
konnte
[Musik]
zwischen 1928 und 35 grad ist den
geheimen laboratorien des biochemikers
krieg burri maria noski ein breites
spektrum geschmackloser farblose
prognose und tödliche gifte zu schaffen
die leicht in speisen oder getränke
appliziert werden können ohne dass davon
etwas mitbekommen würde
dank seiner vielen fortschritte und
erfolge wurde meiner noski teil des
teams von pawel suchow platz auf einem
agenten des sowjetischen geheimdienstes
nkwd den vorgänger des kgb und heutigen
fsb
zu douglas tor war für die eliminierung
aller personen verantwortlich die als
staatsfeinde galten danke mayr allofs
kies neuen ägypten konntest du klar
tus-team seine gesamte vorgehensweise
auch revolutionäre art ändern einer
weile spielten sie mit recht
bezahlmethoden herum wie zb pralinen
schachteln mit sprengstoff sehr schnell
aber hatten sie den dreh raus und
vergiftung wurde zu einer der
wichtigsten vernichtungs methoden gegen
andersdenkende in der sowjetunion dann
jedoch stark stalin und der neue boss im
kreml
rostock setzte die installierung ende an
inklusive der aufklärung der begangenen
verbrechen und zu jener zeit wurde eine
doktrin eingeführte bis heute gültigkeit
hat offiziell wurden uns foto
planungsmethoden verurteilt er selbst
1958 zu 15 jahren gefängnis verurteilt
das alles ändert jedoch nichts daran
dass die regierung insgeheim weiterhin
an seinen methoden festhielt denn diese
hatten sich als sehr effektiv erwiesen
[Musik]
es wurden immer mehr ressourcen für die
entwicklung neuer substanzen locker
gemacht sie sollten noch wirksamer sein
und noch schwieriger aufzuspüren warum
nun die antwort auf diese fragen ist der
historiker boris tvo das tun sie müssen
den tod oder die krankheit ist opfers
als natürlich erscheinen lassen oder
zumindest symptome hervorrufen
die ärzte und gerichtsmediziner vor
einem rätsel stellen zu diesem zweck
entwickelte die kamera ihre bestimmende
spezialität die kombination bekannter
gifte im originellen und unauffindbaren
formen boris bukowski
denn mit der fortentwicklung der
giftstoffe wurden auch die medizinischen
und forensischen techniken zu ihrer
aufdeckung immer besser ein
fortwährender wettlauf vergleichbar mit
einer anderen russischen spezialität
neben doping im sport das ganze system
funktioniert nur wenn man immer einen
schritt voraus allerdings gibt es im
gegensatz zum doping auch eine andere
kategorie des einsatzes wenn es kann er
nämlich gar nicht darum geht unentdeckt
zu bleiben sondern eher darum einen
gegen eine eindeutige message zu senden
dann sind andere eigenschaften gefragt
zum beispiel dass der todeskampf des
opfers besonders qualvoll ausfällt und
dies auch genügend leute mitbekommen
zu diesem zweck wurde lange polonium 210
verwendet diese giftige substanz
hinterlässt eine breite radioaktive spur
die mit einem geigerzähler leicht
nachzuverfolgen ist im jahr 2006 wurde
damit in london der von russischen fsb
zum britischen text übergelaufene agent
und putin kritiker alexander litwinenko
vergiftet bereits in den 1980 er jahren
starteten die sorte jetzt jedoch eine
weltweit einzigartiges
entwicklungsprogramm für nervengifte
namens foliant dieses brachte unter
anderem das gefürchtete new york hervor
[Musik]
norwich ob das auch für russisch sowas
wie neuling bedeutet ist eine gruppe
hochgradig tödlicher neurotoxin die von
sowjetischen wissenschaftlern in labors
in ordnung kasachstan usbekistan und in
russland selbst entwickelt wurden sie
können in form einer flüssigkeit eines
pulvers oder eines euros transportiert
werden und sind extrem leicht in ein
anderes land zu bringen um 6 im exil
leben und dissidenten auszuschalten ohne
an der grenze entdeckt zu werden
diese gruppe von giften hemmt die
kundenliste rasen in denen sie die
neurotransmitter angreift die in den
zellen die wesentlichen funktionen des
körpers regulieren
dies führt zu einem versagen
lebenswichtiger organe und ist nur sehr
schwer von den symptomen einer
zufälligen akuten erkrankungen zu
unterscheiden darüber hinaus kann und
damit je nach gewählter dosis einen
menschen zu holen mit absoluter
sicherheit töten oder diesen auch die
chance lassen gerettet zu werden um eine
warnung auszusprechen
niemand weiß genau wie viele gegner und
dissidenten die udssr mit dieser art von
geheimoperationen ausgeschaltet oder
gequält hat allein aufgrund der
bekannten zahl von programmen
infrastruktur und ausrüstung zur
durchführung dieser operation kann
jedoch davon ausgehen dass die zahl der
opfer in die tausende geht
der sowjetische geheimdienst kgb gegen
nach dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
so gut wie nahtlos in den russischen fsb
über der name ändert er sich zwar aber
seine strukturen und methoden das
personal und seine ausbildung blieben
die gleichen tja und einer davon war
kein geringerer als wladimir putin
selbst genau
der heutige präsident ist ein ehemaliger
kgb agent und wie heißt es so schön
never change a running system
deswegen ist dieser modus operandi heute
auch in putins russland noch immer
lebendig vor allem wenn allen
klargemacht werden soll dass man
entweder für oder gegen das regime ist
und du stellst ich sicher ist die frage
ob diese methoden im jahr 2020 wirklich
immer noch funktionieren oder ob sie in
der russischen gesellschaft nicht doch
unmut erwarten nun die antwort darauf
wollen wir die nicht vorenthalten
[Musik]
neues ausland alte gewohnheiten
wenn es etwas gibt mit dem putin gerne
vor seinen freunden an gibt dann ist es
sicherlich die tatsache dass ihn niemand
etwas anhaben kann
und am besten ist man da zu sein gegner
nicht nur einen schritt voraus
deswegen hat putin seine methoden und
auch seine mentalität ständig
weiterentwickelt in der ukraine
er lebt im jahr 2004 der eu us
präsidentschaftskandidaten viktor
juschtschenko nach einem abendessen mit
dem russlands ordentlichen chef des
inlandgeheimdienstes ihrer smash pro
eine akute dioxinvergiftung ein erstes
team in wien konnte sein leben retten
und stellte die zweithöchste jemals bei
einem menschen gemessene
dioxinkonzentration fest geschenke
überlebt später antwortete juschtschenko
auf die frage ob präsident putin in
seiner vergiftung involviert gewesen
sein
mit der aussage er habe dazu eine
antwort aber er werde sie nicht
aussprechen europa solle erkennen dass
die größte bedrohung für seine bürger
eine russlands weit dass im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
mittelalterlichen methoden anwendet
einige jahre später wurde dann wie schon
erwähnt alexander litwinenko in london
mit polonium vergiftet er starb nach
einem qualvollen drei wochen dauernden
todeskampf im krankenhaus und zwei tage
vor seinem tod unterschritten renko
einen abschiedsbrief in dem er den
russischen präsidenten putin für seinen
tod verantwortlich machte um die
mögliche beziehung zwischen diesen
ereignis und der russischen regierung zu
verstehen muss man aber ein paar jahre
zurück gehen nämlich in den oktober 2006
als die russische journalistin anna
politkowskaja im aufzug ihrer wohnung
erschossen wurde
politkowskaja aber eine putin kritischen
journalistin welche mit besaß all die
drohungen und die zensur durch die
russische regierung zu ignorieren dann
jedoch stark sie in ein wespennest
besonderer qualität
sie wollte verbrechen der regierung
putin in tschetschenien und die damit in
zusammenhang stehenden korruptionsfälle
untersuchen und das machte sich offenbar
zu einem vorrangigen ziel eines das zum
schweigen gebracht werden musste bereits
2004 wurde bei einer reise nach beslan
gibt im tee verabreicht sie erkrankte
schwer überlebte aber scheinbar handelt
es sich um eine letzte warnung und
tatsächlich gute sie dann im oktober
2006 ermordet und mit dem lenker
vor seiner stiftung wollen die seltsamen
umstände von politkowskajas tod zu
untersuchen und nur einen monat später
war er selbst tot seine mörder waren
zwei russische agenten die sich als
geschäftsleute getankt mit ihm in einem
hotelzimmer getroffen hatten
mit dem gift polonium 210 wagens in der
aktivität tisch umgegangen dass nicht
nur das ganze hotel zimmer radioaktiv
verseucht wurde sondern auch das
treppenhaus des hotels und eine nahe
gelegene diskothek in der die russischen
agenten gewesen waren ein strahlendes
handtuch tauchte sogar in der wäscherei
auf nein nicht strahlend weiß sondern
radioaktiv verstrahlt all diese spur
enthalten scotland yard genau zu
rekonstruieren wurde im wörther gewesen
waren und wann die vergiftungen
stattgefunden hatte eine ähnlich
dilettantisches vorgehen hat übrigens
auch bei der namentlichen
identifizierung der täter im fall report
und vielleicht fragst du dich jetzt wie
es denn sein kann dass der
hochprofessionelle russische
geheimdienst derart stümperhaft vorgeht
und ob diese türke ausführung nicht er
darauf hinweist dass wohl jemand anders
dafür verantwortlich ist nun nicht
unbedingt denn gerade solche clowns die
es das sind die markenzeichen der
russischen geheimdienste ja geradezu
eine tradition im jahr 1940 überlebte
der weißtal in ungnade gefallene
ehemalige revolutionär leo trotzki ein
anschlag dieser exil in mexiko toski
wurde in seinem haus von mehreren von
stalin entsandten agenten attackiert die
sich als mexikanische polizisten
verkleidet hatten
allerdings eben auch so dilettantische
weise dass die länder öffentlichkeit an
eine inszenierung also eine durch toski
selbst geplante fonds fleck operation
glaubten sie dachten trotzki wolle damit
stalin international diskreditieren und
sich selbst wieder in den mittelpunkt
rücken
sie hatten unrecht und auch die dünnsten
agenten haben irgendwann erfolg wenn man
nur genug von ihnen losschickt drei
monate später war trotzki tod ein
spanischer kommunist und npd agent
erstach ihn mit einem eispickel und
deswegen hält russland bis heute an
dieser strategie fest
[Applaus]
so wurde zum beispiel der russische
politiker und journalisten ali mika ramm
wurst sah gleich zweimal vergiftet das
erste mal im jahr 2015 und erneut im
jahr 2017 beide male trug er schwere
gesundheitsschäden davon karama war
berater des 2015 in moskau ermordeten
oppositionspolitikers ihrem software sie
auf einen fußtritt aktivist verlor 2018
plötzlich sein augenlicht sein gehör und
konnte nicht mehr gehen
er wurde zur behandlung nach deutschland
gebracht wo ärzte eine vergiftung fest
stellten und so gibt es eine lange liste
an fällen nur aus den letzten jahren für
den politisch gesinnten mörder hat das
vergiften einen entscheidenden vorteil
es verbindet leichtere streitbarkeit mit
bösartiger theatralik selbst wenn der
mörder jede beteiligung leugnet
vielleicht mit einem verschlagenen
augenzwinkern
stirbt das opfer einen schrecklichen und
oft langsamen tod eine
unmissverständliche botschaft aus gift
flasche
aber was ist mit all jenen gilt
anschlägen an menschen die nicht so
prominent sind die oppositionspolitiker
und journalisten ein schlüsselfaktor der
sich durch all diese geschichten ziel
ist dass die fälle von denen wir wissen
oder deshalb bekannt sind weil sie
entweder außerhalb russlands aufgetreten
sind oder weil es den opfern gelungen
ist zur medizinischen behandlung ins
ausland zu gehen herauszufinden wie
viele weitere fälle in russland selbst
unentdeckt bleiben ist praktisch
unmöglich und die russische regierung
will von all dem natürlich nicht wissen
und bietet immer ab verweist darauf dass
es sich wohl um persönliche racheakte
und ähnliches handeln könnte
dieses argument höre ich schon seit
vielen jahren von politkowskaja
überlebten enco bis zum skript all das
ist unmöglich der kreml sein kann
sondern jemand der versucht dem kreml zu
gefallen aber das problem mit diesem
argument ist dass die situation im jahr
2020 nicht mehr so ist wie sie 2004 2006
war es ist wirklich schwer vorstellbar
dass jemand es wagen würde etwas so
drastisches zu tun oder es sich vorher
irgendwie absegnen zu lassen um sicher
zu gehen dass er oder sie sich auf der
sicheren seite befinden nun diese
einschätzung macht durchaus sinn nicht
wahr und was glaubt die russische
öffentlichkeit was wenn die normalen
russischen bürger überall diese
anschläge nun diese frage ist nicht
gleich zu beantworten denn wenn ivan
normal russe etwas während der letzten
12 100 jahre gelernt hat dann dass es in
machtfragen besser ist seine ohren augen
und mund fest geschlossen zu halten aber
trotz all dem für die na wann die
opposition bei den regionalwahlen am 13
september 2020 recht gute ergebnisse ein
der ball nicht verkündete gewannen zum
ersten mal in der geschichte regionale
vertreter und sorgten dafür dass putins
partei einiges russland in den zwei
großen sibirischen stadt tomsk wirst in
mehrheit verlor aber die wahrheit ist
auf jeden fall das ist wie russen nicht
nur im hinblick auf repression und
politische konsequenzen äußerst
gefährlich ist nicht aktiv zu äußern
es ist auch schwierig für sie schutz zu
finden denn wenn es in dieser geschichte
eine traditionell unmissverständliche
botschaft wird dann ist es folgende wir
kriegen dich egal wo auf der welt nur
dich versteckst denn wer sich gegen uns
stellt ist nirgendwo mehr sicher so und
was meinst du wie sollten andere länder
und die internationale gemeinschaft
deiner meinung nach auf diese
giftanschläge reagieren sollten
operationen zur tötung politischer
gegner im ausland als eine verletzung
der souveränität angesehen werden und
ist diese art der vernichtung
politischer gegner eine rein russische
spezialität stichwort julien assange
bitte schreib uns alles was ihr das so
einfällt in den kommentarbereich unter
dieses video
wir hoffen dass er dieses video gefallen
und vielleicht auch etwas gebracht hat
was ja gibt uns auch einen daumen hoch
und unterstütze uns in denen du es mit
einem präsent ist und vergesst bitte
nicht dass eine jede woche neue videos
hochladen werden also verpasst kann es
unser updates abonniert unseren kanal
und klickt auch auf das klingt symbol um
rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu werden
macht's gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]